what do you call a sad cup of coffee a
depress Oh many of us cannot imagine our
day without having a cup of coffee
we all pray for it especially when we
wake up in the morning actually it's not
the coffee that we crave for but a
special component which is present in
the coffee and the special component I'm
talking about is none other than
caffeine wait a second
what exactly is caffeine and what is so
special about this component that it can
bring us back to life let's find out to
begin with caffeine is a stimulant that
is it stimulates various activities in
our body stimulates in what sense it
helps us to stay alert focused makes us
feel energetic and more importantly it
keeps us awake and happy quite a few
right this stimulating substance can be
found naturally in more than 60 plants
to name a few it can be extracted from
the seeds of coffee beans cacao beans
and Kola nuts but we know that anything
that stimulates us can be considered as
a drug so tell me is it right to call
caffeine a drug absolutely now what
happens when this drug called caffeine
enters our body what special power does
it have to make one active aren't you
curious
let's begin with the journey of caffeine
in our body and see what revelation it
has for us consider this situation often
long hours of any activity we tend to
feel tired and sleepy
the main culprit for our tiredness is a
chemical molecule known as adenosine
which is a sleep inducing molecule when
we are continuously doing any activity
or during the course of the day
adenosine molecules slowly get
accumulated in our brain our brain has
receptors which help in collecting these
molecules these adenosine molecules bind
with these receptors and make us feel
tired and drowsy if we are able to relax
a bit in such a situation we are lucky
but if we are not that lucky then we
definitely need a Savior to rescue us
from being tired and drowsy and who is
going to help us you guessed it right
it's it caffeine the structure of a
caffeine molecule looks similar to that
of an adenosine molecule caffeine
molecules fight with the adenosine
molecules and take the place of
adenosine to bind with the receptors
once these caffeine molecules bind with
the receptors our brain is charged up
with energy and we feel fresh all this
happens within a span of 20 minutes
amazing isn't it
now do you think the effect of caffeine
remains in our body forever obviously
not that's because the life of caffeine
is approximately five to six hours after
that the effect of caffeine reduces in
our body and gradually our brain slows
down its activities that is we are back
to being tired and drowsy after all it's
a stimulating drug and the effect wears
off to charge up again our brain demands
another
cup of coffee all right now tell me if
we start consuming coffee frequently
does it mean that we would remain more
energetic and fresh all the time no
that's not true
her brain is smarter than we think it is
it starts creating more adenosine
receptors which means that even though
we consume more coffee the overall
effect of caffeine will not be that
significant
isn't that great now guess what Kaffee
not only makes us energetic but also
happy it's like our happy pill one cup
of coffee down our throats and their
cheerful how does this happen let's
understand Kathleen has a power to
induce the effect of dopamine in our
body and what exactly is dopamine
dopamine is an organic substance that is
released when we engage in pleasing
activities like eating an amazing meal
listening to our favorite music hugging
the loved ones and of course after
having a sip of coffee and do you know
what happens when dopamine level
decreases in our body it leads to
diseases like Parkinson and Alzheimer
does caffeine plays a major role in
maintaining the dopamine levels an
interesting thing to note here is that
caffeine is not only found in coffee but
also in tea soft drinks chocolates and
in caffeine pills in decide quantities
Wow so much happiness around us wait
earlier we've seen that caffeine is an
addictive drug and acts as a stimulant
as every drug taken in large amount is
harmful do you think even caffeine is is
it possible to overdose caffeine in our
body
and what would happen if a coffee addict
suddenly stops drinking coffee this is
your cue box to explore take a sip of
coffee and tell us your findings in the
comment section below do subscribe to
our channel to learn interesting
concepts happy learning